[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue d'anciens en
parler sport c'est le premier numéro de
cette saison sur tb 78 on ne change pas
une recette qui fonctionne au programme
comme toujours une dose de bonne humeur
des analyses sportives et surtout des
coups de gueule et des à débat est
aujourd'hui en fait un événement c'est
le retour de nos chroniqueurs en plateau
après des mois de vision présentation en
musique on commence à ma droite il ne
tient plus en place depuis plusieurs
jours ils voulaient absolument revenir
sur le plateau de thé déficiente vite
c'est un passionné à 2 cyclisme le
capitaine yann chevalier piste 1 open 2
p l'isi 78 tutelle soir mickaël oui
heureux d'être de retour parmi vous sur
deux réseaux oui vraiment content
vraiment content d'être là et en plus on
va parler de sujets très intéressant et
passionnant donc beau on y va on va voir
ça on continue notre tour de table
musique c'est le meilleur d'entre nous
il connaît tout sur tout c'est un fin
connaisseur du monde du sport et les
journalistes chez tv 78 c'est notre
italiana lover grégory canal et sort
avec nous pendant une heure grégory
bonjour michael bonjour diane bonjour à
tous et un italien glover vainqueur en
plus cette année une année italienne
tonitruante voilà je tiens à le préciser
je voulais savoir l'hôtellerie
l'eurovision l'euro de football record
de médailles aux jo record de médailles
aux jeux paralympiques le titre en euro
féminin de volley bref si l'année
l'italienne vraiment au top et vous avez
intégré l'équipe du sop sport également
une super année bonjour tirer mes
lunettes et par respect pour mes
camarades au et c'est ma première sur le
sop sports avait du monde avec du monde
en plâtre donc on est content on est
content et d'ailleurs juste sur l'euro
petit aparté je tiens à laver ma
réputation de mauvais pronostiqueur
j'avais dit
on avait dit voilà on prête d'être un
mauvais pronostiqueur dans les équipes
finalistes de l'euro j'avais mis italie
angleterre finalement c'était la finale
de l'eau en quoi c'était votre année
voilà il était mon année on continue à
ma droite musique lui aussi et
surexcités à l'idée de retrouver le
plateau il n'en dors plus la nuit depuis
plusieurs jours il est à très bon en
visio mais il est excellent en plateau à
le gladiateur de rugby club de
versailles pierre chevallier et avec
force et bonheur à tous ça fait vraiment
plaisir de vous retrouver de retrouver
les plateaux c'est un grand moment
effectivement une grande première après
envoyé des agents 18 mois à peu près 18
mois sans se voir son ce sens être à
côté sans pouvoir ajouter le 11 mars
dernier c'était 11 mars on trace 2020
2000 en un mois une éternité quand on
est deux bacs on en a gardé le meilleur
pour la fin musique ce plateau c'est
chez lui et il est ravi de revenir pour
y mettre le feu une nouvelle fois au
sens figuré bien sûr c'est le chouchou
des téléspectateurs
mesdames et messieurs jaunisse ex
entraîneur de plaisir c'est avec nous
bonjour ical et bonjour à tous comment
allez vous comme tout le monde super
content de revenir sur le plateau
vraiment pleine bourre en pleine forme
près tout ce qu'on est tous partis
presque bon quelque chose près
alors on va commencer par de la boxe on
va parler du dernier combat de tony hawk
a perturbé par la mobilité de pétards
millas le croate l'yvelinois originaires
de chanteloup les vignes a réussi à
trouver la solution par un enchaînement
encore à la fin du septième rang d' tony
hawk à 29 ans sort vainqueur par ko de
ce combat qui s'est tenue à roland
garros devant plusieurs milliers de
spectateurs c'est sa onzième victoire en
onze combats disputés dont 9 par k o
cette victoire peut-elle le faire
rentrer dans le coeur des français oui
ou non vous votez
vous êtes partagés grégory pons ou c'est
non non pour vous pierre chevalier vous
êtes partagés gens et vous yann vous
êtes partage également rit on fait un
petit duel entre
contre 12 jean et pierre allez c'est
parti premier duel de la saison genre
pourquoi vous êtes partagés alors je
suis partagé pourquoi parce que alors
rentré dans le coeur des français oui
pourquoi pas parce que il ya un moment
qu'on n'a pas vu un boxeur français un
petit peu en haut de la fiche donc au
niveau médiatique je dirais oui pourquoi
pas ça peut le faire entrer le coeur des
français
maintenant mon bémol c'est au niveau
sportif niveau sportif pour moi il n'a
pas encore montré que c'était un grand
parmi les grands cela effectivement 11
au combat ont deux victoires 9 ko mais
me le dire le mal non mais c'est pas mal
d'accord mais si vous jouez et c'est sûr
se bat contre le
lit d'un couple a donc de votre bien
cette expression et des baisses d'impôts
celui qui fait les démarches à la fois
la poignée dans ces jeux pour moi il n'a
pas encore il n'a pas encore combattu
une pointure donc sportivement c'est
pour ça que je mets le bémol parce que
pour moi il n'est pas encore il n'est
pas encore parmi les grands voilà même
ce dernier combat avec cet adversaire
qui était quand même assez vif pour un
brin lourd un poids lourd pourrait
qu'ils étaient très vif les nerfs et
j'ai perdu d'ailleurs été remis la
solide accord fin c'est pareil lui et si
l'ajout que s'il a joué que les
caissières de supermarché c'est pareil
donc
faire ce vallier en justifiant son côté
partagé jean a pointé le bon argument et
qui fait que vous serez d'accord comme
souvent c'est que sportivement on peut
partir et grand chose de ce combat la cg
on avait l'impression que c'était david
contre goliath avec une espèce de petit
moustique là qui tournait autour super
super tonique et avec des bonds jaïbi et
qui il travaillait un petit peu mais en
fait il est ok il ya quand même du mal à
l'attraper au fur et à mesure qu'ils
arrêtent et à être il ya être en fait à
distance et et à pouvoir se mesurer
réellement donc je dirais d'une certaine
manière
ni là ce n'était pas de taille dont
propre et au figuré
d'un combat comme celui là et pour en
tirer des enseignements en disant est ce
que yo ka avec avec son gabarit son
poids dans sa catégorie peut peut se
mesurer aux plus grands sur un combat
comme celui là c'est pas vrai c'est
impossible à dire impossible à dire
alors après il faut le gagner ça reste
ça reste une victoire ça reste une
victoire par ko dans un dans une très
belle enceinte le retour des événements
sportifs avec du populisme en va s'en
souvenir peut-être il y avait du baril
et en plus il y avait du monde y avait
du beau linge il y avait du beau linge
sur ceux sur ceux sur ces combats parce
qu'il faut pas oublier ce que ceux qui
avaient juste avant en début de réunion
mais donc oui il fallait gagner et c'est
très bien par contre je pense que c'est
pas c'est pas c'est pas révélateur d'un
niveau de championnat du monde par
exemple il ya déjà les vous êtes
d'accord avec pierre et jean finalement
qui sont en plus ou moins d'accord
j'irais même jusqu'à dire rien à ajouter
parce que en effet je voulais parler de
l'enceinte je trouvais que faire un
combat de boxe
l'après belmondo si c'était leur incombe
à l ess a cédé entre guillemets au
patronat de lézards du calendrier voilà
donc jean sol viendra final bien sûr
mais bien sûr quand on se souviendra
je lui ai même lu que j'avais pensé j'ai
même lu que on se souviendra peut-être
plus de l'hommage à jean paul belmondo
que du combat en lui même donc donc
voilà après après je trouve enfin voila
moi j'ai quand même beaucoup de mal avec
la boxe encore plus et j'en parlerai
plus tard dans notre émission avec par
rapport à ce qui s'est plus passé aux
jeux aux jeux olympiques cette année
encore une fois
donc pour que your car entre et pour moi
yoka il est déjà dans le coeur des
français par rapport à ces aux résultats
et en plus à l'image qui peut avoir avec
avec sa femme bmo redire son service et
salue estadio cas
mais donc déjà voilà il il a quand même
ce côté emblématique dans le coeur des
français où ils sont un couple un peu
atypique et puis son sympathique l'image
qu'on peut en dégager ils ont gagné une
médaille d'or aux jo directeur aux joj
au voilà donc c'est vrai qu'il y avait
des gars ce côté sympathie au niveau des
français maintenant ça reste un sport la
boxe qui reste quelque chose de
marginal même si c'est le sport noble ça
reste quand même un sport un peu un peu
marginale dans l'esprit d'aider des
français et pour et puis voilà il va
falloir aller taper des boxeurs beaucoup
plus d'aidé non plus clinquant et là moi
je j'ai tapé j'ai sorti le top 20 des
ddd comment s'appelle le top 20 des
poids lourds voilà des poids lourds
ibi 15e dès 15 heures voilà et je pense
que il aimerait taper un top 10 et c'est
vrai que ce sont des outils justement à
la c'est vrai ce serait le bon le beau
l'adversaire parce que
il à tony a en ce combat sans défaite et
une journée 13 donc c'est vrai que ça
pourrait être le combat sympa par la
suite et son adversaire en finale amelio
de 2016 donc quand il l'a déjà battue et
ça lui permettrait de conquérir une
deuxième ceinture ce que tony yoka il a
eu cette ceinture l'union européenne
face à son dernier adversaire adversaire
tambouille dzeko et il a il doit
conquérir cette ceinture ebu avant
d'aller chercher un titre mondial moi je
suis d'accord avec ce que disait ah yan
sur le côté il est déjà dans le coeur
des français avec son couple avec
estelle il ya ce titre olympique en 2016
maintenant sa conquête c'est comme ça
qu'il l'a appelée c'est l'émission qui
va consacrer la chaîne cryptée canal+ eh
bien on en est encore loin la conquête
c'est d'aller chercher ce titre mondial
il s'est fixé comme objectif 2022 ça va
être très difficile si le combat pas
joyce je suis d'accord avec toi yann au
moins avant la fin de l'année il faut
déjà battre
un top mondial à un méchant c'est une
vraie affiche est il a dit à la fin de
son combat il a été je veux un top 10 et
en plus leader ce n'est pas combattue
depuis 2010 neuf donc ça renforce encore
plus voilà le fait qu' il affrontait un
adversaire c'était à deux demandes roger
dispo samedi
avait été ça avait été évoqué un temps
et finalement les promoteurs avaient
préféré un autre challenger pour joyce
donc pourquoi pas le voir avant la fin
de l'année on parle aussi de plus en
plus de voir tony yoka les combattre en
chine puisque son promoteur bob arum a
pas mal de contacts dans les casinos de
macao donc ça pourrait être pas mal
aussi a l'habitude de faire de gros
combat c'est notamment de boxe et chez
les poids lourds notamment devoir
peut-être une renommée internationale le
combattant dans les 20 premiers call
moins de combat donc il faut encore
qu'il s'aguerrisse et je pense que il
lui faut un top 10 il lui faut encore
cinq combats mais avec des mecs du top
20 pour pouvoir pour pouvoir
prendre encore encore de l'expérience
pour aller chercher un top-5 parce que
là en effet c'est du très très lourd
nous allons maintenant passer au
programme de l'émission n'hésitez pas en
tout cas si vous avez d'autres tops nous
proposer alliés dujarrier le top des
tabatières dans les idées de sorties
pour le dimanche n'hésitez pas alors
aujourd'hui nous allons parler à des
sportives paralympiques évinois présent
cet été à tokyo coup de projecteur
également sur la retraite internationale
du pistard de l'équipe de france
françois pervis l'illinois était cette
fois à champion du monde mais avant de
développer ces thèmes en a parlé des
jeux olympiques de tokyo et des
performances de nos hadjis vinoy
[Musique]
on va donc parler des performances de
nos sportifs évinois aux jo de tokyo on
va décortiquer les performances de
chaque sportif du 78 présent cet été au
pays du soleil levant et vous allez me
dire si leurs performances peuvent être
considérés comme des tops ou des flops
on va tout de suite commencer par deux
l'aviron est la sportive de 23 ans à
claire bové la rameuse licencié à
mantes-la-jolie monte sur la deuxième
marche du podium avec sa coéquipière
laura à taranto là le duo termine juste
derrière l'italie pour seulement
quelques millièmes de seconde une
première médaille pour l'aviron français
féminin depuis
1996 l'italie pâtit
celle là pour le coup vous auriez pu
vous la laissez
alors top ou flop
sur cette performance de carbo mais bon
vous est unanime pour vous bien sûr
au delà de la petite blague sur l'italie
n'en top forcément si on prend lé
objectifs qui étaient fixés par claire
bové et laura taranto là c'était un
podium olympique l'objectif est rempli
c'est vrai qu'il ya la petite amertume
d'avoir ce titre olympique qui échappe
pour quelques millièmes de seconde il
faut pas oublier que ça faisait 25 ans
que cette médaille olympique et bien
fuyait l'aviron français c'est les
derniers jeux olympiques c'est la plante
et en 96 et donc rien que pour ça on ne
peut pas dire que c'est un flop c'est
quand même une grosse performance qui
est fait pas recette yvelinoise d'accord
il ya une cherrier c'est quand même un
peu rageant quand même de perdre pour la
même pas un visuel de bateaux sur le
moment bien sûr que c'est rageant bien
sûr que l'on se dit pourquoi j'ai pas
mis plus mais après avec le recul comme
tu viens de dire à 25 ans c'est pas
comme si on y était c'est pas un 25 ans
25 ans qu'on n'avait pas eu de médaille
voilà c'est pas comme si on était une
nation forte dans cette dans cette
discipline donc voilà c'est un très bel
exploit je pense que l son jeune 23 ans
et donc du coup elles peuvent se dire
mais on a dans trois ans on ne sera à
paris et là il y aura du public en plus
on aura une motivation supplémentaire et
ça pourra jouer ça pourra je vais faire
la différence à pierre chevalier ça
reste une médaille peac3 il ya trois
médailles possibles dont les aider dans
toutes les disciplines et le nombre de
sportifs qui s'y préparent sportifs et
sportives
avec les paralympiques et autres sans
cesse en fait énormément les sessions
quatre ans cinq en cinq ans pour le coup
là sur tokyo donc donc une belle
réalisation passe pas loin mais on
l'avait rencontré en tout cas juste
avant les jeux olympiques elle à le
viser l'or clairement podium minimum et
or je kiffe ainsi possible ce qui fait
un objectif à temps au volant objectif
intègre quand il a dit ian 25 ans
alors va maintenant à parler de boxe
encore une fois déception pour maiva
hamadouche éliminé a dès le premier tour
des moins de 60 kg en boxe la boxeuse
d'elancourt n'aura pas réussi à trouver
la solution face à la finlandaise miraa
pote collège on l'a même senti très
énervé à la fin du combat a expliqué ne
pas avoir vraiment compris les décisions
des juges maiva hamadouche c'est quand
même un nom dont la boxe française avec
notamment 22 victoires en 23 combats
chez les professionnels un titre de
champion du monde cette performance est
elle un top ou un flop
flop pour vous mais déception voilà
inception
change nous élus a dégainé le premier à
les îles non parce que flock par rapport
aux résultats sportifs c'est sûr mais
j'ai quand même la déception c'est un
gros problème la boxe là haut niveau les
flics avec le phrasé c'est un gros
problème je dis pas fait ils subissent
pas si vous devriez sur les orane
arbitrage et là c'est pas les heures
passées la france 1034 oui c'est sûr la
france surtout quand même donc on va pas
jouer les paranos mai ce qu'elle se fait
voler quand même le combat
du cucs et on se dit les français on
était sympa avec eux à rio ils ont gagné
pas mal de titres bamakois l'esat et
voilà et parce qu'on a parce que à
landreau les alliés les affaires
d'arbitrage avant rio égal à londres il
ya eu l'idée d'aller très vite et des
stocks que ça fait beaucoup mais côté
hommes et femmes il ya que l'arbitrage
qui explique peut-être la mauvaise
performance de mamadou ce
que leur victoire ne soit pas que
si si on en avait beaucoup parlé en fait
de cette boxeuse
juste avant qu'on chante sur cet îlot
parce que c'était mon bébé le potentiel
médaille aux jeux olympiques mais après
c'est le facteur x qui fait kiffer qui
fait basculer la décision la décision
finale on peut pas dire que c'est que
l'arbitrage si elle avait été vraiment
au top dans son combat et si elle avait
été s'il avait été vraiment au rendez
vous il y aurait même pas eu besoin
d'une décision d'arbitrage donc on va
dire c'est l'arrêt cx et que que la foi
de l'arbitrage mais ça a pesé quand même
lourd dans la balance avec une
incompréhension quand même global sur
toutes les questions du respect oui
justement du troisième ronde quel père
alors qu'elle est à deux doigts de
mettre ko finalement la finlandaise
c'est sûrement pour ça qu'elle est
possible qu'elle le père de se critiquer
les décisions d'arbitrage
de parler de d'aviron ou sajoo au chrono
a très peu et en effet à la photo finish
il n'y a pas de discussion larbitre
prend une décision là sur la boxe je
suis désolé larbitre peut prendre une
décision qui derrière sera très très
discutable et est en effet voilà et est
pour moi la boxe aux jeux olympiques ne
respecte pas les valeurs de l'olympisme
et aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on essaye de
faire depuis des années on essaye de
réduire les sports et de réduire le
nombre de d'athlètes etc je pense que
pour moi là si on enlevait la boxe ce
serait pas une grosse perte
on peut comprendre
les difficultés à face à cet adversaire
quel qu'il avait battu me semble en
finale du championnat d'europe 1 c'est
la double championne d'europe en titre
après c'est vrai oui il ya des
constatations à faire là effectivement
la décision et s'est joué sur trois des
cinq juges qui ont
en la faveur de la finlandaise qui en
plus avait écopé d'un avertissement dans
le troisième round imsand donc c'est
vrai qu'on peut voilà on peut mettre en
avant cette amertume et
les quasiment de carreaux mais on peut
l'étendre à l'ensemble du clan français
il ya eu forcément le cas de mourad
alief voilà y'a de cela il ya plein
d'exemples dans ces géo mais mourad
alief qui a même été jusqu au tribunal
administratif du sport pardon pour avoir
peut-être une une correction sur sa
disqualification il n'a pas eu c'est
vrai que on peut être frustré après ces
décisions arbitrales aux jo donc ça
reste quand même un flop selon vous
malgré cette décision d'arbitrage 1.10
nodingues sportivement
c'est pas un exploit premier c'est la
seule coxers française en lice on
attendait beaucoup on la pressentait
comme porte drapeau finalement il ya eu
déjà cette petite déception c'est vrai
que sur le plan sportif on peut être que
déçu on est obligé de dire que c'est un
flop sur le plan sportif quand on lui
souhaite bon courage pour la suite de sa
grève parce qu'elle va continuer à un
chez les professionnels à faire à des
combats on va maintenant à parler de
triathlon en individuel léonie perriot a
terminé cinquième du triathlon a féminin
l'athlète licencié à poissy de 26 ans
finit à seulement 45 secondes du podium
en une heure 57 minutes et 49 secondes
sur la même course 400 beaugrand de
poissy a abandonné enfin chez les hommes
en individuel d'orient coninx a terminé
17e par contre en relais mixte le club
de poissy abri et léonie périodes
d'orient conax et cassandre beaugrand
avec l'estonien vincent luis remportent
le bronze de retour dans la commune de
poissy nous avons recueilli leurs
réactions moi ça fait ça fait un long
moment maintenant j'essaie vraiment
jeune quand j'étais au club donc ça fait
vraiment plaisir de le partager que
c'est parce que justement ça fait très
plaisir de ramener la médaille à la
ville c'est vrai que bah c'est notre
partenaire phare donc ramener ça mon cas
monsieur le maire mais à tous les
pisciacais ça fait vraiment très plaisir
alors est ce qu'on peut dire que c'est
un top ou un flop finalement médailles
de bronze géo en ovalie mixte mais en
individuel cinquième seulement pour
enfin seulement l'une des plus belles
performances sakr pour léonie berio et
abandon pour cassant beaugrand par
exemple qui était l'une des favorites
est ce qu'est ce qu'on pensait d'eux de
poissy traîtres ont globalement est-ce
que ils ont réussi leur gillot oui oui
oui bah oui québec finalement
faut quand même remettre ces
clubs qui met trois éléments dans
l'équipe de france qui est liée aux
enjeux aux jeux olympiques sur quatre en
effet il aura manu mais de bronze donc
globalement c'est même pas une équipe de
france c'est l'équipe de poissy qui a
gagné une équipe yens 75 % est fixé le
seuil des 120 dollars des meilleurs
clubs d'europe
si on perd du triathlon ce dans la
globalité c'est ben oui parce que
vincent luis il est double champion de
d2 fois champion du monde sur les
derniers sur les deux dernières années
voilà il est on attendait beaucoup de
médailles en toute heure de ce tri et la
grosse déception après c'est pareil là
le programme olympique était compliquée
parce que les épreuves étaient à 4
heures du matin
d'édification parle de l'oni période
c'était ses premiers jo voilà son son
résultat individuel il est très
satisfaisant le fait la dernière de sa
carrière à l'inde à l'extérieur en plus
sur la science sur des sons djo sur les
yeux sur b j au sortir une top 5 alors
qu'elle n'a jamais fait sur une coupe du
monde au préalable ou sur un championnat
du monde c'est top et justement la finit
2e 1 je crois si mes souvenirs sont bons
sur l'épreuve qui a suivi juste derrière
l épreuve mondiale donc al monte en
puissance c'est tony perriot pierre
chevalier qu'est ce que vous en pensiez
club de titres et ont jugé jeudi que
c'est une c'est une légère déception ça
reste une médaille quand même comme on
l'a dit de toute façon il n'y a que
trois médailles dans la discipline mais
c'est une impression assez globale sur
ces jeux-là de qu'on a été en france
meilleur en collectif est en avance par
contre quand l'individu avait forgé et
saufs en foot on s'est fait vite sortir
effectivement mais si tu fais après le
pilote un bilan sur les sports
collectifs c'est assez remarquable on
entendra peut-être un petit peu plus
tard mais donc je retiens que là aussi
en triathlon on a été meilleur pari que
en a de jolis duels donc oui déception
réception gens c'est d'accord décision
oui on ajustera où il sera ajouté
effectivement je suis déçu parce que
c'est une discipline où on a quand même
l'habitude d'avoir des podiums sur les
rendez vous internationaux championnat
du monde des moins internationale n'est
pas au giro un parent condamnant les
chassent la demande initiale
j'ai bien dis je c'est vrai foot et
megal j'apprécie ce jeu presque ça c'est
la reprise au lait qui jeudi
effectivement une médaille olympique
c'est exceptionnel mais il ya un demi
frère quand même sur ce bronze ou quand
même l'équipe mixte de triathlon glanait
tous les titres mondiaux sur les
dernières années donc la médaille de
bronze moi je vois là il ya quand même
une petite une petite un petit denis
flop on sait elle a même dansé hier à
une médaille un jean je précise pour ça
je cours l'équipe de france aux jeux
dangereux jonas big fat son
objectif c'était leurs avants qui
étaient affichés voilà donc dominer ils
dominent et en relais mixte depuis 2-3
comme dans beaucoup de disciplines on
aura peut-être l'occasion d'en reparler
un bulletin dans l'émission alors en
golf en toile heureuse leurs
pensionnaires du golf de la boulie à
versailles est terminée à la 45e place
de l'épreuve individuelle qualifié au
dernier moment le golfeur de 28 ans
était pourtant au 15e rang après deux
tours dans le tournoi le français s'est
dit un peu déçu après sa performance lui
qui nourrissait de grandes ambitions à
tokyo cette performance est elle un top
ou un flop
pierre chevallier vous êtes scruter les
flops également alors pierre chevalier
donc ils connaissaient bien
jongler entre nous de mettre les pieds
dans le plat le golf le golf aux jeux
olympiques c'est pas c'est pas assez par
reste c'est pas vieux donc c'est
relativement récent il y avait il y
avait il y avait eu rio et maintenant il
y avait eu tokyo ça donne l'occasion à
finalement des presque des illustres
inconnus de ceux de se distinguer pour
leur pays les professionnels ne sont
vraiment pas tout cela pour ne pas dire
il y en a pas beaucoup il ya dix ans il
ya très peu de qualité par payer ans il
faut le préciser exactement pas tous
qualifiés présents tout à fait car je
crois à lewaï est de l'île ont invité
parents et font des choix aussi par
rapport aux tournois qui joue au niveau
professionnel l'année dernière c'est
justin rose donc une tête d'affiche
cette année je ne me souviens même pas
le nom du champion de fait l'équipe le
besoin d'air pur pour pour antoine c et
romain l'encaissent aussi langue à ce
que c'est c'est l'apprentissage qui
continuent eux pour eux qu'ils sont qui
sont quand même l'idée de relativement
jeune golfeur c'est un tournant
international scruté par la planète
entière mais plus que les tournois les
tournois professionnels du pitch et
retour par exemple il était dans le coup
au début antoine est effectivement on
aurait on aurait pu les deux tours voilà
on aurait pu penser que qu'il allait
parce que c'est vrai c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment un homme dé moving et en
plus c'est qui qui peut vraiment il peut
vraiment doublé et coiffer tout le monde
au poteau à la fin dont déception parce
que parce qu il est ils étaient dans une
très très belle dynamique bon on en a
suffisamment parlé ici avec les tournois
qu'il a gagnés fin 2020 et début 2000 21
oui des déceptions parce que parce que
c'était à priori à
un tournoi à sa portée un parcours pas
facile un parcours veut pas facile au
japon mais ça va lui ça va lui servir
d'une manière ou d'une autre ont dit oui
lors jeunes reprendra il a 28 ans
ardu à peine à se faire connaître sur
circuit mondial ça va lui servir ça va
il va apprendre en ayant raté le podium
sur la même dynamique c'est déçu flop au
vu de ses biens son ascension de ces
derniers mois pierre on a parlé sa
victoire au qatar sa victoire à dubaï
sur ces derniers mois voilà c'est
l'ascension d'antoine rosemère il se
qualifie au dernier moment pour ces jo
c'est vrai qu'au vu du scénario ou au
début il était pas mal on peut on peut
dire que c'est un flop après ça reste
dans une stratégie de progression on va
le suivre sur les sur les prochains mois
mais au vu de sa son ascension de ces
derniers mois je reste quand même sur le
flop cantonales
et hop on sait que c'est vivre alors
judo hague et auchel du cos de
sartrouville a réussi une belle
performance en remportant face au japon
la médaille d'or en équipe mixte cette
superbe performance a été réalisée avec
clarisse agbegnenou et teddy riner par
contre il n'a pas combattu en finale car
la france avait gagné avant son passage
il avait tout de même remporté ses deux
combats avant top ou flop pour guillaume
chaîne ils dopent équipes dames même
s'il n'a pas combattu au final un jeu
précis musique et de tripoli tout genre
vous apportant du nom parce que personne
n'a parlé
bien sûr c'est fabuleux surtout le judo
focale et gagné sur la terre
sur la terre ancestrale du judo c'est
magnifique magnifique ses deux médailles
d'or et c'est une des plus belles mais
peu importe si la combattions finale ou
pas une équipe c'est l'équipe cadets ya
une équipe un sport collectif qu'il ya
des rams de st les rats plassac qui rate
pas ils sont ko champion qui remporte
les deux combats où il était donc
il a été souvent d'élite et la
wii le seul bémol qu'on peut mettre à la
rigueur son tournoi olympique c'est
d'avoir perdu en 16e de finale mais il
perd contre le champion du monde
il ya un moment où il faut voir qui on
combat et en plus ça s'est pas joué à
grand-chose même le même le mouvement
était incontestable donc il aurait pu ne
même pas être pas de pépins ne pas
pénaliser donc bien sûr judo je crois
que c'est une c c'est un des sports sur
lequel on peut avoir le plus de
satisfactions on avait énormément
d'attentes évidemment on est déçu pour
pour dédier rider avec 1 avec seulement
1 bronze mais en mai il a tellement
gagné que on attendait vraiment une
autre médaille d'or il a quand même été
chercher le bronze parce que là pour le
coup fait lady costaud pour pour
repêchage aller rechercher une médaille
mais cette cette médaille par équipes et
c'est une surprise absolument
fantastique j'ai adoré le l'aspect
surprise en fête surprise et 7 cette
bande de potes qui a dû secret
finalement il ya quand même il ya quand
même du sérieux clients et clientes avec
avec larissa benayoun notamment et
auréolé de ses médailles et qui est qui
ce et qui se fondent au service du
collectif donc même s'il n'a pas même
s'il n'a pas combattu en finale il a
gagné les combats qu'il fallait gagner
en équipe il fait partie de cette de
cette team en or est donc là c'est
vraiment c'était un c'était un bon
moment ce que j'aime et moi sur cette
compétition parti principalement c'est
qu' il pouvait élever de la stratégie
c'est à dire que vous pouvez faire
combattre un
un judoka moins lourd parce qu'il
l'était à la limite d'une catégorie et
d'aller taper un plus gros et clarisse
n'ont pas expliqué le judoka france
judokate française justement était
médaille d'or dans sa catégorie
inférieure de poids inférieur à elle est
allée taper la championne olympique dans
la catégorie supérieure et donc du coup
ça démontre une fois ces gens j'ai garé
acteur pour son équipe première
ces pv ce n'était pas le premier il
écrit son nom en lettres d'or japon au
japon
il est revanchard puisqu'il manque les
jo de rio pour un rien en 2016 il a été
souvent blessé dans les dernières années
là il vient chercher quand même une
médaille olympique alors oui il n'a pas
combattu dans cette finale mais encore
une fois il a remporté l'épreuve et si
les petits villages en carrière pour le
coup quand encore début de carrière il
va peut-être faire paris mais c'est pas
sûr il pourrait terminer sur cette belle
médaille d'or bien sûr alors en
équitation christopher 6 de gaz rend
termine troisième avec son équipe de
concours complet le cavalier de 35 ans
termine également 7e en concours complet
individuel avec son cheval totem de
brécé il devait pourtant être remplaçant
mais thibault valette a abandonné au
dernier moment à cause de l'état de
santé de son cheval ont dès qu'on écoute
justement qu'est stoffer 6 c'était ma
première olympiade donc ce qui n'était
pas le cas de mes deux camarades nicolas
touzaint et karim laghouag donc mois
déjà
bah fallait que je fasse mes preuves
auprès du staff fédéral leur montrer que
que j'étais capable de tenir la pression
parce que sur les jeux olympiques on a
la pression surtout que là maintenant
nous notre discipline les règles ont un
petit peu changé depuis cette olympiade
là avant il y avait quatre concurrents
qui couraient les trois meilleurs scores
compter et là en fait on est trop à
courir les trois corps compte donc en
fait on n'a pas du tout droit à l'erreur
alors il a remporté sa médaille avec son
cheval totem de brécé je le disais
précédemment un cheval qui ne lui
appartient pas c'est un cheval que lui
on confie des propriétaires donc c'est
aussi une belle histoire un pourra pour
christopher 6 alors cette performance
est elle un top ou un flop oui ou non
j'écoute est d'accord verser dans
l'autre
oui je vais venir des mois encore une
fois un bémol pour y installer à titre
individuel vu qu'il était pas prévu et c
est qu il a et qu'il tient là il tient
là il tient sa place donc oui à titre
perso pour lui voilà c'est plutôt un top
maintenant pour une équipe de france
pour moi c'est un flop on était
champions olympiques à rio les landes et
là on ne l'est pas on n'est pas voilà
donc c'est juste pour ça je son point de
vue personnel il est remplaçant et il
est appelé il fait cette médaille de
bronze et en plus ils concourent avec un
cheval qui n'est pas le sien donc toutes
les envies de tous les éléments pour les
armes pour soi voilà c'est ça après
c'est qu'il peut être aussi la
performance ou moins bonnes de l'équipe
de france peut dire qu'on a failli y en
a eu on a eu de mauvais pas être tous
les to leave you n'était pas ouvert il
ya beaucoup de chevaux malades je le
précise avant le début de la compétition
dont tous les meilleurs shows ne sont
pas partis à tokyo petite précision
alors enfin en bâle valentin porte
remporté une magnifique médaille d'or
avec l'équipe de france mais le natif de
versailles et participer à l' aventure
des bleus et remporte la finale face au
danemark 25 à 23 la revanche de 2016
l'arrière droite d'un mètre quatre-vingt
dix remporte ses premiers jeux
olympiques top j'imagine pour vous
attention c'est
le propre d'une balle c'est ça c'est que
même s'il faut en tout ce dont il faut
argent c'est un flop donc voila
voila ça a été un bon les filles
ça c'est dit c'est juste du cjd du
bonheur en barre ce qui est bien c'est
que tu en vises ap d'une chaîne à
l'autre vous aviez le volet donc ça
cette étape c'était on a vécu une fin de
la pièce les importent aussi qui est
l'un des joueurs majeurs cette équipe de
france un wind allemand jean lui fait
partie
et c'est son premier titre olympique
hélas
la triste pour le coup au niveau de la
discipline on attendait les frais de ces
et il aura beau me creuser parce que
c'est vrai qu'on les attendait dans le
marais à paris non moi les filles - les
filles quand tous
ces trois marques aussi voilà c'est la
revanche de rio aussi qui a été
remportée ce double titre homme femme
qui arrivait pas 80 qui avait perdu 1
face au danemark en 2016 je tiens
également le préciser c'est quand même
fou au bhv de d'être capable toutes les
équipes françaises féminine ou masculine
reviennent avec une médaille caunes
s'est
arrêtée le 7 de fabuleuses médaille d'or
du handball français on va continuer à
parler des performances de l'illinois
aux jo je suis désolé gagnent on va
parler
alors ça n'a malheureusement pas été
brillant pour nos vies noir va tout
d'abord parler du cyclisme sur piste il
ya eu cette belle médaille de bronze en
vitesse par équipes avec le trio
sébastien vigier florian grec beau et
ryan et la halle qui s'entraîne au
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines ou encore cette médaille de
bronze sur la course à l'américaine avec
l'ancien trappistes benjamin thomas et
grondin mais a malheureusement c'est
tout matile de gros la pépite annoncé
depuis de nombreuses années n'a pas
remporté de médaille même contre
performance pour les épreuves en
individuel benjamins thomas se rate sur
l'omnium alors qu'il est double champion
du monde clara copponi du vc le ska et
termine 5e de l'américaine et 8e de
l'omnium alors avant de parler de bmx je
vous pose la question sur ce bilan du
cyclisme sur piste français est ce que
ce bilan est inquiétant en vue de 2024
oui ou non tous voter oui pour vous
serre chevalier partagé pour vous jean
louis pour vous et oui ça sinon on est
d'accord oui peu inquiétant d'accord bon
on va vous donner par le gorille vous
qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous après
il ya le paramètre jeunesse 1 qui
rentrent en ligne de compte et je pense
que noria n'est pas d'accord avec ça non
mais en tout cas oui on les attendait
c'est vrai que on attendait au moins
mathilde de gros je pense c'est l'une
des plus grosses déceptions
sur ces voix-là sûr c'est sur ces jo
même si voilà j'en perds mes arguments
[Rires]
non mais j'en perds mes arguments moi à
mon sens peut-être que la jeunesse a
peut être un paramètre un paramètre
explicatif après voilà en axe de 0 22
ans rihanna elle vingt huit ans
sébastien vigier 24 en floride rainbow
21 ans larry la vézère champion
olympique en vitesse individuelle 24 ans
voilà alors oui en effet non non il
avait match que ces baisses un fichier
il ya les matchs que c'est l'âge de 4
ans 24 ans je suis désolé donc on peut
pas on peut pas dire c'est passé passait
pas la même c'est pas c'est pas pareil
sauf que sébastien fins de mois il ya un
gros problème si on prend sébastien
surprend royal si on prend florian ils
sont tous champion du monde junior au
vice champion du monde junior
donc il y a un truc la vraie zen il
n'était pas là j'imagine aisément géo
c'est qu'ils ont mérité l'or mes
compagnons et en plus sincèrement ses
trois garçons qui six mois avant n'était
même pas
préparé pour aligner la vitesse par
équipes tous les trois puisque à
l'époque avant la retraite de grégory
baugé est bien son flanc nord florian
florian game boy ne n'étais pas du tout
le démarreur donc en six mois ils ont
fait un super boulot d'aller chercher
cette médaille de bronze et ça s'est
vraiment joué sur la finale parce que
surtout les pros que les tours
précédents ils sont quatrièmes à chaque
fois derrière les australiens et sur la
finale israël à passer devant les
australiens peut-être justement la
jeunesse a fait son effet parce que les
australiens avaient une image beaucoup
plus vieille ils ont vraiment coincé en
finale c'était le troisième ou de
quatrième match delà de la troisième
match de la journée donc en effet ça ça
commence à tirer dans les tirs et dans
les cannes donc voilà pour moi l'équipe
de vitesse par équipes super ça c'est un
top par contre qu'on vienne pas me dire
qu'ils sont trop jeunes pour pouvoir
faire des tournoi de vitesse
individuelle
non c'est pas vrai ils ont fait des
coupes du monde ils ont fait des
championnats du monde la vraie zen il
fait les mêmes courses que est en effet
y gagnent aussi il est toujours devant
donc là il ya un problème et le problème
il n'est pas sur ces garçons il est
général et à la fédé là il faut se poser
des questions mais je suis désolé
londres c'était un fiasco on ne s'est
pas posé les questions rio pareil on et
revenir les tunnels de bronze faut
arrêter ce qu'il était six médailles
dont six possibles deux ou trois titres
mais oui bien sûr
en général donc je prends route je
prendrais tu étais et vtt je suis désolé
on allait enfin chez les filles on
allait les deux du numéro un mondial et
numéro deux mondial c'est pas normal
elle fuit ski 12 mai en ayant et on se
fait et on se fait traîner un peu moins
mécontent parce que ce ne sont pas des
idées ne sont pas des yvelinois bon ça
n'empêche là je vais parler du cyclisme
en général la seule équipe à la rigueur
chez les garçons sur la route voilà
cinquième place moi je trouve qu'il s'en
sont très bien sortis parce que ben
julian alaphilippe n'était pas là et
c'est notre leader numéro un je suis
désolé c'est pas normal qu'une année
olympique oui il a eu un bébé mais ces
panneaux qui ne viennent pas sur un
champ sur un jeux olympiques mais sur le
cyclisme sur piste là on avait les
meilleures pour vous oui aux rita aucun
problème bah oui on pouvait pas faire
mieux bailly la cie puisqu'on à kevin
solution qu'on en afrique et qui est
deux fois champion du monde des années
précédentes et là bas il n'est pas sûr
idées sur aucune marche donc sur aucun
podium cc c'est pas assez alors après
c'est par ici des courses de peloton
c'est très très difficile mais encore
une fois mais on voit bien que sur les
jo c'est toujours les mêmes qui gagnent
nous on n'est pas là haut mais je veux
revenir peut-être également sur mathilde
euros parce qu'il faut avancer en
émission mathilde groupe qui échoue au
repêchage en vitesse individuelle elle
est éliminée en quarts de finale de
kerry elle avait pourtant réalisé le 4e
30 ans le premier jour elle avait battu
le record olympique en 10 40 avant
d'être dépassé par trois autres
sportives juste après elle a dit qu'elle
a elle été marquée à vie vous vous la
croyez elle est marquée à vie après ces
résultats alors qu'on disait que c'était
peut-être la pépite du sport français du
cercle français c'est ce cas là dessus
offert indiqué marc hervieux au niveau 2
comment comment elle va s'en servir oui
voilà c'est fait je retrouve tout à fait
mais après maintenant il va falloir
qu'elle est peut-être transforme ça pour
bien ce qu'on n'a pas vu des rebelles
finalement matinée en effet le 4e temps
des fêtes quatrième temps au calife
c'est pas normal quand on fait le 4e
temps au khalife de pas de se faire
sortir en quarts de finale en quarts de
finale n'est encore lui l'adversaire
vous avez là je vous êtes normalement
chronométriquement vous êtes largement
au dessus des personnes que des
adversaires que vous rencontrez donc
c'est pas c'est pas logique qu'elle se
fasse sortir en demi finale et qu'elle
nous perdrons qu'elles perdent même pour
la médaille de bronze je pourrais
l'entendre mais là elle doit pas perdre
en quarts de finale donc c'est après
c'est son parcours elle n'a pas l apal
métier et là on se rend bien compte que
aux jo il faut de l'expérience donc
beaucoup de morts
il revient sur la chaise oui mais c'est
à dire qu'au bout d'un moment elles
arrivent pas à passer ce cap de junior à
voilà sur les performances pratique du
basket latine elle vient de nulle part
ce faut pas l'oublier bathilde yahia il
ya quatre ans ou 5 ans maintenant est
déjà monté sur un vélo liste et c'est
une discipline qui est hyper technique
et qui est très fort et elle a eu des
résultats quand même gagné mais bien sûr
mais parce que l abbé qu'elle fait elle
affaiblit y avoir beaucoup de monde elle
a été arrêtée surtout chez les juniors à
décrire toutes les niches et j ai tout
gagné chez les juniors et en effet ces
balles mentale peut-être kiki qui
pêchent aussi peut-être c'était ses
premiers jeux olympiques y avait
énormément de pression j'en ai un
problème de préparation c'est tout
à votre avis les corrections voulues
jean alesi par les experts mais vous
pouvez pas s'exprimer ainsi non je
disais je veux on en a parlé déjà sur ce
plateau mais ces jeux olympiques on a
quand même une équipe qui est assez
jeune et on l'avait dit aussi que
c'était pour les intrigues mais pour
leur montrer ce que c'était une épreuve
olympique et préparer surtout
2024 en france pour la paire formée au
maximum je ne dis pas qu'ils ne l'aiment
pas sa sueur de ses jeux olympiques mais
au moins tu l'as dit tout à l'heure
mathilde grobel est marqué à vie et
comment va-t-elle réagir sur justement
elle a dit qu'elle ne voulait plus
revivre ça voilà donc deux hommes qu'est
ce que ça peut être est ce que ça va lui
donneront en abandonner cyclisme c'est
une option à veiller aérienne de
solution ou alors elle jette l'épongé ou
alors c'est vrai nos plus forte donc ça
peut être ça peut être positif et il ya
des défaites positives espérons que ces
défaites là soit positive pour le
cyclisme français sur route mais si on
joue sur la pression en 2024 encore plus
de pression et de prison ils auront déjà
vécu il aura déjà vécu ce que c'est
c'est vrai que sur les olympiades on n'a
jamais eu le choix dans la date et que
la de tokyo qui est passé de quatre à
cinq ans et puis finalement paris 2024
on n'a pas de on n'a pas de meilleur
moment au fait pourquoi pour aller se
mesurer et là tu sais tout l'aspect
mental qui va jouer s'il a marqué à vie
ok ça on perd on peut le comprendre si
je pense que senna c'est l'orgueil qui
parle parce que je pense que malgré tout
même si elle n'est pas si tu lis de
longue date et les compétitrices de
longue date basketteuses avons cycliste
elle et elle est estampillée pépite
pépite du cyclisme français
je pense qu'au contraire c'est peut-être
c'est peut-être ce qui pouvait lui
arriver de mieux avec une bonne baffe
qu'elle prend comme une comme une
blessure d'orgueil est là et là
maintenant elle a trois ans pour se
préparer et effectivement il y aura
beaucoup beaucoup de pression mais il y
aura aussi beaucoup de repères pour elle
et je pense que ça peut jouer aussi dans
la balance et justement dans une balance
entre la pression la pression qu'elle
peut qu'elle peut absorber et puis et
puis de l'autre cette expérience ce
ressenti et cette blessure d'orgueil et
les repères qu'elle a au vélodrome et en
gros sur le sol français alors va
maintenant parler de nos pilotes de bmx
reis là aussi les sportifs qui
s'entraînent régulièrement sur le
stadium de bmx de saint quentin en
yvelines se sont ratés chez les femmes
allant valentino est éliminé dès son
entrée en lice axel etienne termine 7e
sur 8 en finale chez les hommes par
contre grosse déception sur sept pilotes
3 était en finale silva andré romain
mahieu et joris daudet mais aucun n'a
terminé sur le podium avec notamment une
chute de joris daudet dans la dernière
ligne droite alors qu'il avait le podium
en ligne de mire les deux autres se sont
gênés et silva andré termine 4e je vous
pose la question ce bilan est il
inquiétant également pour 2024 ou c'est
un peu moins inquiétant bmx peut-être
quand ce qui se meut sur piste le bmx le
problème c'est que c'est quand même un
peu plus aléatoire alors joris daudet y
tomber y tombe tout seul c'est quand
même une catastrophe je sais et l
excitation
d'être
française
ils ont caché qu'ils n'ont pas pris le
bon avoine mais non elle a cessé en plus
je dirais à l'arrière ce serait un jeune
qui purent et je vais la voir la
médaille des pays perd ses moyens mais
joris daudet il a été champion du monde
plusieurs fois c'est pas mais là il ya
la marche olympique est en effet il rate
un truc là je pense que il a craqué il a
craqué dans la tête et c'est et puis
alors après c'est pareil je veux dire on
a trois mecs on n'est pas foutu sur le
podium 3 sur cet ingrédient voilà c'est
pas inquiétant je pense je suis il ya
quand même des finales français sur sur
ces épreuves de bmx et c'est décevant
gagné le plus de pilotes en finale
finalement mon arme mais voilà comme dit
comme dit diane 3 3 qui était en finale
et aucun qui termine sur sur le podium
et si on fait ça avec un pourcentage de
chances de corps dont on entendra trois
mecs au départ sur 7 quel pourcentage de
chance d'avoir au moins juste une
médaille sèchement directs au départ
trois qu'ils sont en finale ça c'est
satisfaisant il ya chez un luthier de
scie qui fait une finale côté côté
femmes maintenant il n'y a pas eu ces
titres donc oui c'est décevant
inquiétant pour de paris 2024 non pas
parce qu'en plus de 1024 vous pouvez
refaire la même chose et puis vous fait
le triplé
c'est pas ça n'a absolument rien à voir
c'est vous mettez les mêmes mecs et puis
ça se trouve vous faites 10 fois la
course est 10 fois que vous n'êtes pas
mais le résultat non plus donc le bmx et
à ce côté où il faut être fort mais
aussi ce côté aléatoire de la chute qui
peut arriver de du mauvais départ de
enfin plein plein de choses qui s'est
rien n'est fait ali n'est pas passé on
va maintenant passer notre page coup de
projecteur
[Musique]
alors on devait parler de françois
permis de sa retraite internationale en
aura malheureusement pas le temps pour
cette émission on va leur porter la
prochaine émission on va passer à votre
envolé à grégory de quoi allez vous nous
parler c'est un petit peu notre dessert
ici dans ceux ci ont parlé sport soit et
vu que vous avez travaillé dessus autant
voilà l'appel sans les frères je vous
parlais d'une olympiade alors je ne
parle pas des jeux olympiques qui on l'a
compris le bilan est plutôt mi figue mi
raisin pour le clan français même si
heureusement qu'ils avaient les sports
collectifs pour pour sauver la mise mais
je vais parler des jeux paralympiques de
2020 qui sont déroulés également cet été
du 24 août au 5 septembre à tokyo
l'objectif affiché était de 35 médailles
et bien aux tricolores l'on pulvérisé
54 médailles dont 11 en or 14 en argent
et 28 en bronze une 14e place pour la
france qui va bien plus loin que les 28
breloques obtenu à rio et dépasse même
les 50 de de pékin 2008 donc la
performance était au rendez vous et
parmi les héros de cette délégation
française il y avait bien sûr des
yvelinois on va parler des cyclistes
bien évidemment avait déjà une belle fin
de carrière on n'en a pas parlé on
devait lui consacrer une partie à
françois pervis jura lors de la
prochaine émission angle assez
rapidement mais en tout cas voilà
françois pervis qui pour la fin de sa
carrière en tandem est allé chercher
avec le pisteur déficients visuels
raphaël beau gilet le bronze en
kilomètres à 36 ans il rentre donc dans
le club très fermé des athlètes
médaillés aux jo et aux jeux
paralympiques bravo à lui deux médailles
de bronze moi je retiens aussi un
sourire celui de marie patouillet
sourire très communicatif 33 ans natif
de versailles qui a exercé comme médecin
généraliste dans les yvelines à la
cycliste est né avec une malformation au
pied gauche et restera comme un symbole
de tokyo 2020 c'est la première médaille
française de l'événement et elle est en
bon sur la poursuite individuelle ul et
puis l'athlète a récidivé une semaine
plus tard avec un nouveau bond sur route
pour le court la course en ligne c4 c5
et deux quatrièmes places également à
noter en contre la montre et en 500 m
contre la montre alors nous avons brillé
en cyclisme mais aussi en natation c'est
un peu le miroir à verser 1 des jeux
olympiques avec la jeunesse qui est au
pouvoir pour la natation deux noms à
retenir hugo didier d'ivoire en peut
gagner mais c'est du beau didier natif
du chesnay 19 ans qui est désormais
licencié dans un club de haute-garonne
deux médailles pour lui une en argent
sur le 400 m nage libre s 9 1 bronze
également sur le 200 m 4 nages s 9 et 19
ans tout comme alex portal le licencié
du cercle des nageurs de l'ouest
francilien club de saint germain en laye
c'est un club pourvoyeur de champion et
pour sa première leaf les noix qui a
souffre de déficience visuelle apparu
vétérans médaille d'argent au 200 m 4
nages s13 bronze au 400 m nage libre 4e
place également 100 m papillon et une
justesse aussi dans l'analyse de ses
performances dans les interviews d'après
hé bien les finales à l'export' elle
paraissait tout de même déçu au sortir
de ces cours celui qui rêve de l'an mais
après la décompression vous l'avez
interrogé michael et finalement il est
plutôt satisfait de ses performances
vraiment heureux d'avoir fait deux
médailles c'est surtout la dernière donc
je suis vraiment fier en 200 m 4 nages
je fais l'argent et après sinon essai
c'est vraiment ça décompresse allez on
est parti un mois avec la natation au
japon les parties de 2 août et là on est
en venu le 6 septembre donc ça fait
vraiment du bien de poids se poser chez
soi je prends de l'expérience d'année en
année
manière j'ai vu même pas dans mes
courses au jeu j'arrive à faire des
médailles mais il reste des choses à
améliorer
les phases mon âge et des virages des
culbutes les
écouler après même sur les phases nage
et surtout le dos et la brasse à
améliorer dans le pôle 200 m 4 nages et
voilà après je pense que manière c'est
un suivi global la musculation la
nutrition manière je pense qu'il ya
plein de pour améliorer par vous essayer
de se perfectionner tout le temps et
c'est comme ça que on arrivera
j'arriverai à faire je pense voilà
l'objectif est fixé trois ans
d'entraînement d'ici paris 2024 pour
devenir pourquoi pas champion on
poursuit avec une revanche michael est
celle de timothée adolphe 31 ans natif
de versailles qui a découvert
l'athlétisme à guyancourt où il a habité
l'athlète déficients visuels était
arrivé 5e au 100 m à rio disqualifié
pour avoir mordu la ligne à tokyo le
sportif avait été de nouveau disqualifié
au 400 mètres cette fois ci pour avoir
perdu le lien avec son guide mais
timothée adolphe n'a pas lâché il n'a
rien lâché il est allé décrocher sa
première médaille est dans une olympiade
en argent sur le 100 m t11 avec son
guide bruno nappe rixe comme quoi il ne
faut et jamais abandonné et puis deux
premières sans médaille mais qu'importe
la joie d'être à tokyo était là en
tennis fauteuil notamment avec la numéro
38 mondiale la vie chinoise à charlotte
fairbank 29 ans qui n'a pas passé le
premier tour ni en simple ni en double
avec sa compatriote emmanuel marche et
enfin l'andrésien merrill loket qui
était également de la partie sa
discipline le para badminton est entrée
aux jeux paralympiques cette année le
joueur de 23 ans a échoué en phase de
groupes une défaite une victoire d'abord
un contre le polonais aime rose avant de
céder par deux fois contre les
indonésiens pardon ainsi j'écorche
lennon henry mood 6 nuls gros qui
obtiendront plus tard 1 respectivement
les médailles d'argent et de bronze
enfin un mot je n'oublie pas cécile
sabouraud l'apparat triathlète élan
courtoise qui aurait dû être du voyage à
tokyo mais elle a été victime d'un grave
accident de la route lors de son
entraînement l'essentiel c'est qu'elle
va bien elle se soigne et elle regarde
dorénavant de l'avant j'ai envie de dire
une chose vivement paris 2024 la
question sur ce thème est ce qu'ils ont
performé tout simplement c'est à ces
sportifs là-bas au lors des jeux
paralympiques tokyo oui ou non
oui tout simplement oui vous allez
est-ce qu est-ce que c'est suffisant
parce que on a entendu un truc c'était
pas forcément suffisant ce cas pas moi
sans que votre médaille en lui je pense
que et je pense que on a un problème en
france c'est qu'on se satisfait du
podium et essai et c'est apparemment à
l'export' on ne se satisfait pas du pot
du podium il a fini 2e 3e 4e devra
également mais sans plus tous ne le sont
pas et le problème c'est que dans un gie
je vais prendre la phrase d'un
un entraîneur français qui est
entraîneur cycliste dans un pays comme
la chine et le japon donc rappelez-moi
son nom
un trader pistard c'est pas grave en
effet c'est pas normal de deux
doses auraient de la même manière des
sportifs qui font aimer les deux
d'argent et deux de bronze une médaille
d'or
et donc c'est vrai que c'est un petit
peu le problème est donc du coup on
satisfait d'un podium olympique en
satisfait d'une médaille de bronze et je
suis désolé c'est pas toujours
suffisant alors après je vais prendre
l'exemple de marie patouiller dont il
sait bien je connais très bien qu'ils
étaient là et vais préparer et a
découvert la piste grâce aux 500 mètres
et qui vient chercher une médaille de
bronze sur la poursuite voilà c'est top
parce que en effet ce n'est pas la
discipline qu'elle a préparé plus élevée
elle va chercher une de bronze là on
peut s'en satisfaire mais il ya ce pour
certains athlètes n'est pas le cas et
puis après ils vont plus chercher celle
sur le contre la montre sur la route
mais c'est encore une autre nom sur la
course en ligne d'ailleurs pardon sur la
course en ligne et là c'est encore c'est
encore autre chose et c'était pas du
tout écrit et je peux vous assurer
qu'elle était très contente de ces
résultats et elle peut l'être maintenant
il ya certainement des deux bronzes qui
sont des médailles de rattrapage et on
en recense à dix derrière sur la patrie
des apatrides poulidor donc
effectivement on a cet état d'esprit là
mais qui est en qui je le trouve qui est
en train de changer sur le fond est
finalement depuis 98 des jeannois déjà
sur les sur les titres collectifs sur
les sports collectifs et c'est aussi en
train de changer et d'accompagner parce
que c'est en fait maintenant les
champions d'hier sont les entraîneurs
d'aujourd'hui de demain et que on a on a
justement on a un bon calendrier et
c'est vrai que la montée vers paris 2024
que ce soit chez celle ayant dit chez
les bouchers les valides
c'est assez prometteur et malgré tout ce
ce record de médailles pour la france
paralympique c'est inattendu oui oui il
ya beaucoup de il ya beaucoup de bronze
eppendorf un peu d'or il manque de lits
quand même notamment notamment outils en
fin juillet pas mal de disciplines comme
ça où on était attendue et d'érosion
mais c'est pareil donc ccc monte monte
gentiment en puissance et est sûrement
en puissance vers paris 2024 et quand
même regarder ce ces deux bilans avec
bienveillance oui il ya des déceptions
mais il ya eu aussi des belles surprises
je pense que sur le collectif on est on
est on est là on est au rendez vous avec
avec des surprises donc com de com du
grec vivement paris 2024 genre est ce
que vous en pensez vous votre vie
ou sur les allées à ce jeune homme vous
parlez du parole
objectif 35 54 médailles
de bronze beaucoup de brouhaha me fait
onze médailles d'or et puis cas
lorsqu'on veut sophie sur l'objectif de
35 médailles à tous et qu'on revient
avec 54 quand même je pense quand même
que c'est un événement bassin voie la
voie publique 1 pour
rire elle exportait ne le disait
justement le fait qu'ils aient pas de
public ça enlever un petit peu de saveur
et peut-être un peu de motivation pour
certains donc peut-être qu'il aurait pu
faire peut-être un peu plus de médailles
encore au président certainement mais
bon quand même
certes c'est vrai d'accord on a un peu
de cet esprit français ou en ce contact
le peut mais la
4e n'atteignent pas l'objectif on dit
c'est une
défaite et les désillusions et là on
dépasse à l'argent l'objectif on peut
quand même d'akzenta aussi se féliciter
des résultats c'est ce qui me faisait
mal en fait c'était de voir un pays
comme l'azerbaïdjan au tableau des
médailles qui étaient devant nous parce
qu'ils avaient beaucoup de médailles
d'or alors qu'ils avaient un nombre de
médailles qui était vraiment inférieur
du jeu ces règles je suis d'accord mais
c'est vrai que moi ça me faisait mal
parce que j'en ai fait ses armes et la
chine
il voudrait après voilà les abats de
gens et bien une dizaine d'heures qu'ils
allaient prendre les allées les prendre
en en musculation sur l'éclectisme sur
l'haltérophilie
si on paye le billet d'avion je vais y
aller
mais et c'est vrai que là dessus il
brillait mais moi ça me faisait mal de
me dire pure et ils ont deux fois moins
médailles que nous et ils sont quand
même devant et ça ça me voilà c'était
mon côté un peu amour propre et en effet
c'est pour ça que je dis c'est les mines
d'or qui compte et il faut aller les
chercher parce que tableau des médailles
il est un peu un petit mot sur quand
même cécile sabouraud quand même si son
accident juste avant de partir c'est
assez compliqué forcément pour elle
moins de dix joueurs comme ça j'ai vu la
photo sur les réseaux sociaux mais c'est
difficile de rêver voilà respectez-nous
un peu elle était en train d'allaiter al
été percuté par un chauffard qui en plus
ça a pris la fuite ensuite il ya eu on
l'a suivi sur ces opérations alors j'ai
plus le nom en tête je crois que ces
spin jack ça s'appelle l'opération
l'essentiel c'est qu'à l'arrivée elle a
été touché aux vertèbres lourdement
touché aux vertèbres elle était obligée
de déclarer forfait c'est effectivement
elles sont son vélo c'est enfin c'est
impressionnant quoi s'est il a été
littéralement 6 en deux et donc voilà
l'essentiel c'est qu'elle aille bien
aujourd'hui elle a manqué ces jeux
paralympiques c'est une grosse déception
mais elle garde quand même dans un coin
de sa tête paris 2024 elle espère
pouvoir y être regardé le vélo qui voit
la couper en deux parce que c'est un
très net des piliers des années un fond
cette échéance 1 je tiens à le préciser
dix jours avant accident c'est comment
on fait pour se relever aussi de ça mais
c'est parce que c'est parce que parce qu
elle tend mais voilà c'est un sportif
qui n'est pas constitué comme comme un
sportif de haut niveau tout simplement
juste très ravi d'abord parce que je
sais que tu as un précieux mois pour moi
la plus belle image de ces jeux
olympiques depuis lothar ses idylles
india's l'haltérophile philippines qui
remporte la médaille d'or sacha n'y a
pas de salle de musculation aux
philippines et quelle salle trenet sadr
et des bouteilles d'eau total a reçu
d'ailleurs à la médaille exception de de
l'esprit des volumes pis mme mois pour
moi c'est fabuleux ça voilà voilà les
pick up à lexus pour ne pas faire de
sport c'est ça en vaut pas les suse
voilà rsa c'est le meilleur moyen alors
c'est déjà la fin de cette émission vous
l'avez bien vu agents on va terminer
comme d'habitude par une citation
aujourd'hui permettez moi de citer un
acteur et non pas un sportif je veux
parler de jean paul belmondo il était
tout de même boxeur professionnel est un
grand supporter du psg la citation peut
se prêter au sport il a dit vendre des
années n'est pas très grave car chaque
âge a ses plaisirs et ses bonheurs je
vous laisse méditer sur cette phrase à
bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]